je crois qu'il est temps que je me
présente leinster ling
[Applaudissements]
une toute petite pression 85 grammes sur
le nerf vague et votre copain il fait un
gros dodo laine sterling un espion
légendaire toujours chic et et rouge
walter becker est diplômé du mba ici à
15 ans travaille au labo des innovations
technologiques ya tellement de gadgets
que je voudrais tester sur le terrain
par exemple le câlin gonflables c'est un
genre de dispositif de protection
individuelle que j'ai développé c'est un
gaspillage révoltant de l'argent du
contribuable voici votre prochain
objectif
aucun de nos agents ne parvient
l'approcher
j'ai quelque chose qui peut vous aider
la dissimulation biodynamique imaginer
que j'arrive à vous faire disparaître
helens regardez moi je te regarde je
vois mes fesses et ton visage en même
temps c'est tellement cool être un
pigeon ça peut faire de vous un espion
encore meilleur le bij ans sont partout
et personne ne remarque il est prouvé
que les pigeons peuvent voir hors amm
[Musique]
alors ça c'était gaudin est ce que
quelqu'un a vu un
un pigeon les visions peuvent voler
jusqu'à 148 km air ne me fait pas du
haut de ce heiva se débrouiller
nous y voilà qui mourra stirling tu vas
regretter d'être né il est temps de
faire un gros dodo
mais ma maman
nous avons des talents très différents
c'est ce qu'ils finissent apéritif
walter tu peux certes rôle ce qui se
passe dans le sous marin reste dans le
sous marin
[Musique]